there's a little bit of breaking news we
could bring you um this is coming uh
from the facebook page of colin powell
now he is the former u.s secretary of
state uh and chairman of the joint
chiefs of staff well according to his
facebook page he passed away this
morning due to complications from covert
19.
the statement on his facebook page says
he was fully vaccinated
we want to thank the medical staff at
walter reed national medical center for
their caring treatment we've lost a
remarkable and loving husband father
grandfather and a great american that
from the powell family
colin powell a retired four-star general
he served as the 65th united states
secretary of state from 2001 to 2005.
and he was called the first
african-american secretary of state uh
before
the election of barack obama as
president colin powell and his successor
condoleezza rice were the most highest
ranking african americans
in the history of the federal executive
branch
he also served as the national security
adviser of the states and as the
chairman of the joint chiefs of staff
he had retired recently
and in his retirement he wrote his
autobiography uh but he was still uh
carrying out public uh speaking uh
addresses uh across the country and
abroad and was also chairman of
america's promise which is a non-profit
organization to try to help
mobilize people from
every sector of american life to build
their character and competence so there
will be many tributes undoubtedly coming
him into him in the current minutes and
hours but for now all we have is the
information from his facebook page
that general colin powell the former u.s
secretary of state and chairman of the
joint chiefs of staff has passed away
due to complications from covert 19.